Have you guys heard of soft guy era or drizzle drizzle
it's a new trend or shall I say awakening happening amongst men
Where they’re being more in tune with their emotions
and I wouldn't say that they're more feminine
but rather an adjacent where they now want special treatment too
just like all the ladies
They got bullied so much by woman that now they're letting go of their toxic masculinity
not being aggressive
they want soft guy era energy
they want all the special treatment that women get
they want doors opened for them
They wanna be the passenger emperor
They wanna be pampered
they wanna be spoiled just like any other woman is.
So you better be ready
better be ready to apologize first
pull out chairs for them
the whole nine yards
because guess what
they deserve it and they want it
They’re tired of being taken advantage of
they want to be spoiled just like all the other women
It’s crazy because it's actually working for them
I don't think this movement is gonna end
what do you think?